prendre un autobus et connaître la peur
c'est bien de cela dont il est question
dans l'histoire qui suit un homme de la
chine se trouvaient à bord d'un autobus
de la stm tôt dimanche matin quand des
personnes sont montées à bord et l'ont
agressé pour le volet car il ne vous
avez rencontré ce jeune homme oui un
jeune homme de 30 ans un étudiant en
architecture effectivement il a eu la
peur de sa vie il a décidé de témoigner
de ce qui est arrivé dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche parce qu'il veut
sensibiliser les gens être extrêmement
prudent dans les autobus
il aimerait aussi que la stm mettre des
caméras dans tous les autobus côté de la
stm on nous dit qu'il ya des caméras
dans les autobus de nuit seulement mais
lui il aimerait que ce soit dans tous
les autobus donc il a eu extrêmement
peur intimider mais je voulais c'est
leur justement l'écouté parce qu'il
raconte très bien ce qui est arrivé
c'était vraiment comme la pire année de
ma vie je suis prêt a dit maintenant
j'ai vu la mort celle qui s'élève puis
il vient s'asseoir à côté de moi mais
dans la possibilité d'y jouer dans son
manteau de chercher un objet genre moi
je vais en objet métallique je me suis
dit c'est sûrement couteau donc j'ai
commencé vraiment avoir craint pour ma
vie
ils sont l'objet disque un email il fait
en sorte que je puisse les voir
donc je peux la voir c'était la tête de
mark twain acier du métal massif que
celui du cash
je vais te donner au québec et là il se
met debout
il se lève puis il m'a proche y dit
qu'on comptait jusqu'à 3% dans la cage
il ay fè mais y meurt il m'a même pas
donné le temps des chercheurs mais pas
pour le cash il ya eu une intervention
rapide de la police quand même ça a
donné lieu à des arrestations
oui grâce aux maîtres siens en fait qui
ont réussi à trouver deux jeunes en tout
cas il y en a trois qui ont été arrêtés
m 2 qui ont été accusés formellement un
jeune de 17 ans et un autre de 19 ans
qui est connu des milieux policiers
alors c'est gênant devront faire face à
la justice des accusations de vol
qualifié agression armée complot et
possession d'armé dans un dessein
dangereux
donc on le comprend ce monsieur eu
extrêmement peur est tenté des
poursuites au civil
premièrement il ya peut-être un procès
criminel c'est effectivement il ya des
accusations formelles qui sont portées
contre l'homme de 19 ans qui devra se
présenter devant le tribunal
à la mi mars et pour le jeune de 17 ans
ce sera devant le tribunal de la
jeunesse ce mercredi merci beaucoup
quand même
ouah ouah